if there's any country that could be the
poster child of a green political agenda
it's most certainly Germany it's a noble
pursuit no doubt but the green vanguard
is learning the hard way that everything
has a price we is industrialized
countries also need to be on the front
line in terms of doing something to
overcome our carbon footprint and stop
changes in the climate or reverse the
rise in temperature if we push for
climate protection it will cost money
this money is well spent if we're ignore
it I think it will cost us more money
that's the truth do nothing is no
alternative the fact is that we will
then pay more the captains of Germany's
car industry responded to Merkel's
request with a resounding yawen they
unveiled their latest most futuristic
electric cars in Frankfurt after
billions of euros of investment of
course perhaps they were trying to take
a step towards the flying cars of
science fiction
at any rate many are saying that paying
for the future is only leading to the
destruction of the present the green
socialist ideology is running our
country and taking away any chance we
have for the future your so-called
climate protection is nothing else than
a monstrosity industrialization program
combined with veritable job destruction
so you waste billions to avert imaginary
Doomsday's in the distant future we're
not just hearing this kind of talk from
politicians though a new report says
that renewables are threatening
shortages in Germany's energy supply and
the country hasn't even come close to
its energy transition goals Germany is
missing most of its self-imposed targets
for the energy transition by 2020 at the
same time energy supply security is
being jeopardized in the medium-term by
the decision to phase out nuclear and
coal emissions Germany's over reliance
on wind and solar energy has created a
big deficits times of little wind or Sun
the government has imported energy from
neighboring countries to avoid blackouts
and just to balance 2019 s energy budget
Germany had to foot a bill that
skyrocketed to 38,000 euros for a
megawatt of power per hour as compared
to just 64 euros in 2017
not to mention that everyday Germans pay
the highest energy prices in all of
Europe we have the highest energy costs
in the world the price for energy is the
highest in the world because of this
change of the supply system a situation
is very ridiculous I mean they made a
big fast last year for 200 200 hectares
of forest for coal mining at the same
time they're cutting thousands of
hectares of forest for windmills killing
hundred thousands of animals I mean this
is no green policy I mean right now the
situation what we have in Germany is
that the Green Party started as an
environmental party but now they changed
now there are climate climate paranoia
party which sacrifices everything for
the climate situation of no it doesn't
matter
human beings nature animals no losses
our losses are justified this energy
crisis may have Germany teetering on the
brink of recession and to stay afloat
it's gonna need that world renowned
powerhouse of an auto industry it's
built instead car makers are being
pressured to produce expensive electric
cars that don't even sell that well
Volkswagens chief already warned that
perhaps this is all going too far
the current campaign against individual
mobility and conventional cars is
reaching a threatening level instead of
using petrol or diesel will basically
use coal even if we're electrically
powered and in the worst case will even
use lignite that takes the idea of
electric mobility to absurdity
nevertheless environmental organizations
are marching and mass on Saturday
joining them will be a brigade of
cyclists calling for an end to the
combustion engine hopefully it won't
translate to an end to the German
economy Germany was very safe on energy
supply and everything everybody's used
that energy is always available but with
getting more and more vent mills into
the into the system the system gets more
and more unstable and we have seen in
the last month several times that a
collapse of the energy supply system we
passed by only very slightly
governmental policy in Germany is
distracting our the backbone of our
industry
which is the car industry of course from
Germany and for example works well if
they announced already beginning of this
year that they wanna gonna get reduce
twenty thousand people just because of
immobility only in Germany it's a big
economic game or all competitors I mean
plants are closing down here in Germany
because of the regulations and reopen in
China where they can produce co2
unlimited
you